entrusted in the limo company in saying  oh it's okay they're fine  he trusted that because that's the type  of man that he was he was very  trustworthy he was very compassionate  especially about people and you believe  it was that trust that cost him his life  yes absolutely absolutely if he was  alive and this happened and all these  people died didn't know how devastated  he would have been did you ever get a  chance to see the fleet to see any of  the limousine I saw them I thought they  were good I thought they were  nice-looking but I'm not a mechanic I  don't know the insides and out of how a  car is supposed to be and What did he  say about the sons and the owner this  company they wouldn't good people he  thought they were nice you know I met  them I never had a inkling of them being  you know any other type of way I thought  they were good people